the congressman who accused trump of
treason may have been
literally in bed with the chinese the
biden team tries to grab a preemptive
credit for vaccine distribution and
democrats are interested in coveted
relief
now that the election is over i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like the government spying on you
well then visit expressvpn.com to stay
anonymous we'll get to all the news of
the day in just one moment first
quick note you're spending too much on
your cell phone bill you are and you
really don't know what you are getting
in return
for that money if you call your big cell
phone provider well they will tell you
that you're getting unlimited coverage
you're getting a limited talk unlimited
text
limited data you don't need the
unlimited data this is where they get
you with the up charge
you could be saving over 800 a year just
by switching to pure talk from verizon
at t or t-mobile
think about it what would you do with
that extra money pure talk has the same
coverage same bars as one of the big
carriers
but they charge you half the money and
you don't have to sacrifice customer
service their team is based right here
in the us
they're some of the nicest people you
will ever talk to so go get unlimited
talk text and two gigs of data for just
20 bucks a month and
if you go over on data usage they're not
going to charge you for it grab that
mobile phone
tile pound 250 say ben shapiro to get
started when you do you say 50
off your first month dial pound two five
zero say keyword ben shapiro pure talk
is simply smarter wireless again a lot
of these big cell phone providers
they're going to ensure that you have no
idea what exactly you are paying for but
with pure talk you know exactly what
you're paying for again that's unlimited
talk text two gigs of data
20 bucks a month if you go over on data
usage they're not going to charge you
for it to get started grab that mobile
phone dial pound 250 say ben shapiro and
you save 50
off your very first month alrighty so we
begin
with the latest in the election 2020
development
the supreme court yesterday rejected a
republican challenge to pennsylvania's
election results
so effectively this means that the
electoral college is going to vote the
way that
pennsylvanians appear to have voted
meaning that president trump
in the electoral college is in serious
trouble we knew this already
in order for president trump to win in
the electoral college he would have had
to shift from the vote totals in
pennsylvania and arizona
and in georgia as well we'll get to
georgia in just a moment the supreme
court rejected an appeal
by pennsylvania republicans that would
have blocked certification of the
state's election results granting
those electoral college votes to
democratic presidential contender joe
biden according to emily zenati over at
daily wire
cnn reports that the decision not to
take up the appeal was unanimous
justice samuel alito was responsible for
ultimately refusing the emergency appeal
but there were no justices dissenting to
the decision originally alito wanted to
accelerate the process by which the
court decided
whether or not to take up the appeal and
then they voted nine nothing including
all the conservative justices
not to take up that appeal there are
solid legal grounds for them not doing
it
they suggest for example that internal
state affairs are internal state affairs
it's not up to the federal government to
decide whether universal mail and
balloting
is a good idea in a particular state or
even whether it violates the state
constitution
in that particular state that's why you
have a supreme court of the state of
pennsylvania as politically biased and
terrible
as it may be and i believe it is both
apparently the justices
also moves quickly tuesday was the final
day pennsylvania could certify its
election result and ensure that votes
would be counted when congress tallies
up the final electoral college vote in
january the supreme court issued a
one-sentence ruling denying the appeal
just hours after a final brief was filed
and just hours before
the deadline the order said simply the
application for injunctive relief
presented to justice toledo and by him
referred to the court
is denied and this basically ends the
possibility of legal challenges
in pennsylvania at this point you're
hearing some people saying in the trump
camp
that it wasn't a denial of a writ of
certiorari okay the problem was that
this case
was never appealed for a writ of
certiorari this case was simply
appealed for injunctive relief meaning
stop stop the certification of the vote
and the court said we're not going to
stop the certification of the vote so
now
if they wanted to move forward with this
sort of case they would have to appeal
for a writ of certiorari presumably
after the electoral college
actually certifies its own votes so this
means that time has
essentially run out in pennsylvania now
this does not mean
that time has run out in georgia as we
talked about yesterday on the show there
is this georgia case
that is actually fairly well
substantiated at least according to the
plaintiffs
suggesting massive voter regularity
inside the state of georgia
jackie diesen hosted the jackie daily
show over at blaze tv was on
this show this radio show yesterday and
she explained at length what the georgia
lawsuit
was about let's put it this way if the
plaintiffs can demonstrate that what
they are alleging is true
then it is quite possible that you could
see the state of georgia reverse now
that would not reverse the results of
the election you'd have to again reverse
in arizona and pennsylvania but it would
be a massive thing
if georgia's votes were found to be so
rife with fraud and voter irregularity
that you have to reverse
the actual results of the election there
and then throw it into the
state legislature for the selection of
another slate of electors here is jackie
diesen
one of the lawyers on that case this set
was going forward
before we had the video based on very
cut and dried points such as about
500 felons voted about 66 000
underage people voted about 5 000 voters
voted
who had left georgia and registered in
another state
under georgia law that means you're
automatically disqualified from voting
and so much more i would say over 100
000 people
are listed here who illegally voted who
should not have voted
and that's all the president has to show
to either get a new election
or to certify the current one so it
should not be hard to demonstrate that
given the nature of those allegations i
mean you're talking about about a 12 000
vote gap between biden and trump all you
have to show
is that 12 000 ballots or more were cast
illegally or fraudulently
and then the results of the election are
thrown into turmoil and doubt
and the numbers that jackie is alleging
right there are
well in excess of 12 000 votes so
there's been talk on the on the side of
the georgia secretary of state is my
understanding
that the plaintiffs in this particular
case the trump team that they are using
outdated voter registration information
and they are comparing
the votes that were taken to that
outdated voter registration information
but we'll have to see because that one
will end up in the courts and that one
actually is a serious and
well-substantiated lawsuit in a
non-serious non-well-substantiated
lawsuit a federal judge in wisconsin
quickly ruled against a request by the
gop
and yet another one of sydney pal's
kraken lawsuits during a status
conference
on tuesday afternoon this according to
law and crime u.s district judge pamela
pepper began
the hearing by noting she would deny the
plaintiff's request for an evidentiary
hearing spent the overwhelming majority
of the rest of the proceedings
explaining why that was her chosen
and necessary court the course of action
the case concerned william
feehan an elector for president trump
whose lawsuit requests a court order
that would quote
overturn and decertify wisconsin's
election results mandated statewide
manual recounts of ballots cast in that
presidential election
declare that trump won the electoral
college votes and pounds all election
equipment the judge said that this is a
pretty extreme request
and that this actually the original
lawsuit did not actually contain
the phrases necessary to support such a
hearing
she said that the the authority to even
hear the case was called into question
she said there's no point in holding a
hearing tomorrow i have to make a
determination as to whether i have the
authority to hear
the case at all because there are a
bunch of justiciability issues
raised by the state defendants and
various interested amicas who have filed
briefs cautioning
eastern districts of washington against
accepting the case again this is a
federal state issue this is one of the
big problems
that has been prevalent throughout this
entire process which is that the the
trump team keeps going to federal court
in order to file for injunctive relief
instead of going to state court and one
of the big problems here is that these
are all internal state law issues
and by the way if you are a conservative
you should actually want these to remain
internal state
law issues and not be elevated to the
federal level why well you may have
noticed that democrats over the past few
years have been attempting to federalize
all of our state elections they've been
attempting to grab control of state
elections
it's one of the platform planks for joe
biden and the democrats is to
quote unquote restore the voting rights
act provisions that required
pre-clearance in particular districts
across the country in terms of
gerrymandering so you'd have some
commissions staffed by democrats at the
top levels of the federal government
determining
how georgia could redistrict or
determining how kansas could redistrict
it would be a disaster area so you
should sort of be careful what you wish
for
in terms of seeking federal relief when
it is internal state business
exactly how they handle their election
so long as they are not actually
depriving
the people of the state of a quote
unquote republican form of government
right that actually is a federal
guarantee is a republican formal
government
in each state under the constitution of
the united states
so bottom line is that the electoral
college date is nearing it is december
9th december 14th is when the electoral
college meets there's a safe harbor
provision that says that all the states
are supposed to certify by december 8th
that doesn't mean it can't be reversed
it means that the burden just went up
and right now the only serious lawsuit
that i see
on the table is that lawsuit in georgia
i will inform you if there are any
others we'll bring you
any other update on all of that in just
one second we're gonna get to corruption
inside congress because it is pretty
amazing
how a story that should have engulfed
the political world yesterday absolutely
did not
and it may have had something to do with
the fact that the person who has now
been engulfed in this particular scandal
has a d next to his name we'll get to
that
in just one moment first let us talk
about the fact that this holiday season
you're looking at ways to buy gifts for
friends and family
you may be looking at a gift for
yourself and you're thinking yourself my
goodness i thought i had more money in
my account
than i did well one reason for that is
because you've been spending too much
money on your insurance why not shop
around
that life insurance policy you were
responsible you actually did get your
life insurance policy you want to make
sure your family was taken care of
but now you need a better life insurance
policy and this is why you need
policy genius policy genius combines a
cutting-edge insurance marketplace with
help from licensed experts to save you
time and money
right now you could say 50 or more by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for more than a decade the
savings really do start to add up here's
how it works first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price policy genius will
then compare policies starting at as
little as one dollar a day
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape the best
part they work for you not the insurance
company so
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll take care of
everything that kind of services earn
policy genius a five-star rating
across over 1 600 reviews on trustpilot
and google so if you have loved ones who
depend on your income don't go into next
year without life insurance instead head
on over to policygenius.com get started
you could save over 50
by comparing quotes and start that new
year with one less thing to worry about
okay so yesterday a massive scandal
broke
and this really is a massive scandal it
turns out that there is a suspected
chinese spy who is targeting california
politicians
according to axios.com which is not a
right-wing
source a suspected chinese intelligence
operative developed extensive ties with
local and national politicians
including a us congressman and what u.s
officials believe was a political
intelligence operation run by china's
main civilian spy agency
between 2011 and 2015. the woman at the
center of the operation is a chinese
national named fang fang or christine
fang
she targeted up and coming local
politicians in the bay area and across
the country who had the potential to
make it big on the national stage
according to axios through campaign
fundraising extensive networking
personal charisma and romantic or sexual
relationships with at least
two midwestern mayors fang was able to
gain proximity to political power
according to current and former
u.s intelligence officials and one
former elected official
even though u.s officials don't believe
that fang received or passed
unclassified information the case was a
big deal because
there were some really really sensitive
people caught up in the intelligence
network according to a current senior
u.s
intelligence official among the most
significant targets of fang's efforts
according to axios was representative
eric swalwell now
you may recall that eric swalwell spent
years suggesting that donald trump was a
russian
cat's paw who was actually compromised
by his relationship with the russians
and now turns out that in all likelihood
eric swallow was stopping a russia a
chinese spy
that seems to be the most plausible
scenario here and tucker carlson
reported last night that this is exactly
what intelligence sources are suggesting
was that eric swallow was literally in
bed with a shiny spy
and he was simultaneously decrying or or
just
a couple years later he was decrying
president trump as being in bed with the
russians here is eric swalwell circa
suggesting that president trump was a
traitor working for the russians
you remember judiciary do you believe
the president right now has been an
agent
of the russians yes i i think there's
more evidence than he is
yes and i i think all the arrows point
in that direction i haven't seen a
single piece of evidence that he's not
an agent like in the 1940s where he had
people who are reds to use in all time
like that in other words working for a
foreign power he's working on behalf of
the russians
um so he was working on behalf of the
russians meanwhile erickson was working
the chinese
or the chinese were working him or there
was mutual working
in any case uh fang took part in
fundraising activity for swahili's 2014
re-election campaign according to a bay
area political operative
and a current u.s intelligence official
swawwell's office was directly aware of
these activities on its behalf according
to the political operative
that same political operative who
witnessed fundrais fang fundraising on
sualwell's behalf
found no evidence of illegal
contributions apparently fang didn't
make direct
contributions but fang did help place at
least one intern in swelwell's office
according to the same two people and
interacted with suawell at multiple
events
over the course of several years so here
is the statement from suaville you ready
for this
representative swala long ago provided
information about this person whom he
met more than eight years ago and whom
he hasn't seen in nearly six years to
the fbi
to protect information that might be
classified he will not participate in
your story
this is not edifying gang it turns out
that if you say
that you are not going to turn over
information because it might reveal
classified information
and the entire story is whether you
passed classified information to a
chinese spy
that is not a good look eric swalwell
according to the and to the axios
reporters in the years
since the fan probe the fbi has
prioritized investigations into chinese
influence operations
creating a unit in may 2019 within the
bureau solely dedicated to countering
beijing's activities at the state and
local levels u.s national security
officials believe the threat posed by
china has only grown with time
a current senior u.s intelligence
official says she was just one of lots
of agents
fbi director christopher wray said in a
2020 speech beijing is engaged in a
highly sophisticated malign foreign
influence operation
these efforts involve subversive
undeclared criminal or coercive attempts
to sway our government's policies
distort our country's public discourse
and undermine confidence in our
democratic processes
and values so um apparently
fang's friends and acquaintances said
she was in her late 20s early 30s when
she was based in the us she was enrolled
as a student at a bay area university by
the way there should be a basic
principle at work here which is that if
you are a chinese national who fully
intends on returning to china and is not
applying for american citizenship
then you should be put in line behind
everybody else who wants to get into
college
we should not be educating and that
should be true by the way of virtually
all
foreign nationals if you're a foreign
national from any country particularly a
country
that is adverse to the interests of the
united states the united states should
not be providing you
with some sort of discounted education
one of our top universities so you can
then go back and work
for your home government that is not
something the united states should be
engaged in it is not in the national
interest of the united states
to do so that is again that is
particularly true when you are talking
about a chinese government that
routinely
apparently uses these sorts of
educational institutions as gateways
in order to enter into circles of
influence we'll get to more of this in
just one second because
as you will see this would be a story
that blow up the world i mean imagine
that there had been a republican
presidential candidate in 2016
who was literally apparently sleeping
with a with a foreign spy
and that came out even a couple years
later and let's say that that person was
on the intelligence committee
okay because eric swallow turns out is
on the house intelligence committee
would that be a national scandal or
would it not be a national scandal the
fact
that axios reported this and that it
didn't blow up in the media
is demonstrative of just where our media
stand they have to cover for democrats
under any circumstances by the way you
know this who knows this
eric swalwall he suggested the reason
that he was being gone after here
is because he was anti-trump yes famous
pro-trump website axios right of
jonathan swan fame
yes i'm sure they reported on eric
swalwall because they wanted to get that
guy because he was the anti-trump
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about a
fantastic gift
any time of the year but particularly
during holiday season so you really
can't travel to see family and friends
or at least if you're thinking about it
you might be thinking twice about it
but you do want them to see your face or
you want to see their faces
why not go over to myphoto.com it's a
game changer it's just awesome
you can go to your cell phone you can
take a photo you send it in to my photo
and they will immediately send back to
you all of the
all of their products with your photo
featured upon them and we're talking
about these beautiful creations metal
glass wood more i have acrylic creations
at my house they're just gorgeous they
shine
in pictures of my kids pictures of me
and my wife it literally takes two
minutes to do
you get it in five days it comes in a
stunning gift box with the holidays
coming up
you don't need to do anything to make
something so personal and special these
guys have literally made millions of
customers memories come to life
including my own these are really
it's a fantastic gift you got to try it
right now go to myphoto.com
you can easily see your photo on all
their products and then simply purchase
you can use the promo code ben25 today
for 25
off i've used it myself i know the
owners of the company really solid
excellent family people go to
myphoto.com right now use that code
bend25
get 25 off you'll see how easy and fun
it is and because it's so quick and easy
it's also addictive you can fill your
home with photos that mean something to
you rather than just having them
expire on the cloud it's easy it's fast
anybody can do it
myphoto.com right now use that code
bend25 get 25 percent off okay so
apparently fang used political
gatherings civic society conferences
campaign rallies and campus events
to connect with elected officials and
other prominent figures according to u.s
intelligence officials
bay area political operatives former
students and current and former elected
officials who knew her
u.s intelligence officials believe she
was overseeing likely unwitting
sub-agents whom she helped place
in local political and congressional
offices so unwitting sub-agents would
mean that she made friends with somebody
she then mainlined them into particular
congressional offices and every so often
she might call to check how things are
going at that congressional office for
example
thing attended regional conferences for
us mayors that allowed her to grow a
network of politicians across the
country
she also engaged in sexual or romantic
relationships with at least two mayors
of midwestern cities over a period of
about three years
at least two of those separate sexual
interactions with elected officials
including one
of these midwestern mayors were caught
on fbi electronic surveillance of thing
according to two intelligence officials
axios was unable to identify or speak to
those elected officials
and by the way she was walking in high
circles she volunteered for rokhana's
unsuccessful 2014 house bid he
eventually ended up in the house in 2016
and is part of that social justice
warrior aoc crowd
he's sort of a bernie sanders acolyte
kana's office said he remembered seeing
thang at several indian-american
political gatherings but did not have
any further contact
with her apparently by the way worth
noting
swalwell's office was in fact contacted
by the fbi and warned about all of this
as eli lake over at bloomberg has
pointed out kind of weird
how eric swalwell's office was
immediately notified that
there was some sort of intelligence
breach inside of his operation
but when the fbi found out that perhaps
the russians were attempting to
compromise the trump campaign
they did not go to trump and inform him
that the russians were attempting to
compromise his campaign
just weird how that worked apparently
fang helped with a fundraiser for
representative tulsi gabbard in 2013.
she appears in photos over uh over
multiple years the host of california
politicians ranging from kana and
swalwell to representative judy chu
of california and representative mikonda
that doesn't mean that she compromised
all of those people and it is true that
politicians meet an awful lot of people
but the swalwall thing is apparently a
lot closer than that
apparently u.s counterintelligence
officials said they believe fang acted
at the direction of the china
china ministry of state security that's
the country's main civilian spy agency
u.s officials first noted fang through
surveillance they were conducting on a
different person
a suspected chinese ministry of state
security officer working undercover as a
diplomat in the san francisco consulate
the suspected officer used that
consulate as a base to do outreach to
state and local level u.s politicians
including inviting them on trips to
china
by the way this is not the first time
that we have seen that the chinese
compromised
american politicians for example there
was all sorts of talk
about how the chinese were essentially
planting moles in various areas of the
california government including with
senator dianne feinstein
and martian writing back in august of
2018 for the washington post imagine if
it emerged that the republican chairman
of the house or senate intelligence
committee had a russian spy working on
their staff you think it would cause a
political firestorm
this month we learned that senator
dianne feinstein had a chinese spy on
her staff
who worked for her for about 20 years
was listed as an office director on
payroll records
served as her driver when she was in san
francisco all while reporting to china's
ministry of state security through
china's san francisco consulate
the reaction of the mainstream media at
the time was barely a peep feinstein
acknowledged the infiltration she said
five years ago the fbi informed me it
had concerns an administrative member of
my california staff was potentially
being sought out by the chinese
government to provide information but
she said he never had access to
classified or sensitive information or
legislative matters and was immediate
and was immediately fired
but again that is just the latest in the
that is just the 2018 version now we
have
versions that were coming out same
period in which apparently chinese spies
were sleeping
with american politicians in order to
gain
access to intelligence senior us
intelligence officials provided multiple
defensive briefings around 2015 to warn
targeted local and national politicians
about fang's connections
to chinese intelligence and potential
chinese assets in their offices
and again u.s intelligence officials
provided multiple briefings to white
house officials and members of congress
on the case and then fang immediately
left the u.s when this became public
she had planned to travel to washington
dc to attend a june 2015 event
shortly beforehand she said she couldn't
attend because she needed to go back to
china she went back to china
and she just stayed in china at the time
now the reason that they've been going
to the bay area the chinese
is because this is number one a place
for people to hide there's a heavy
chinese population in the bay area
apparently some of america's most
powerful politicians got their start in
the bay area as well right i mean gavin
newsom is bay area politician kamala
harris is bay area politicians dianne
feinstein is bay area politician suawell
is a bear bay area politician apparently
according to axios the mss
has a unit dedicated solely to political
intelligence and influence operations
in california silicon valley is also a
great way and a great place to
infiltrate
and of course the bay area has a heavy
chinese population so it wouldn't be too
hard to plant a mole
in that population and then you know
create a life for
that person that of course is no
indictment of the extraordinary chinese
american population
in the bay area it is just a recognition
that if you're going to hide a spy in a
population you need people who seem to
be members of that population obviously
so this is where things stand apparently
in 2011 she enrolled as a student
at csu east bay she served as president
of the school's chinese student
association and president of the campus
chapter of asian pacific islander
american
public affairs which is a national
organization encouraging asian americans
to get involved in civic affairs and
then she used that
as a lever in order to get into politics
and she had an uncommonly close
relationship
with the chinese embassy and she used
these
bay area campus organizations as a sort
of calling card
to allow her to to gain access to power
several acquaintances in political
circles told axios fan was charismatic
and well-liked others described her
behavior as secretive and even
suspicious because she was as it turns
out a spy
according to axios fang's ties to
swalwell which began when he was a
council member for dublin city
california
demonstrate china's long game swallow
rose prominence rapidly in late 2012
became one of the youngest members of
the us house in january 2015
swallow was assigned to seat on the
house permanent select committee on
intelligence
serving as lead democrat on the
subcommittee on cia oversight
apparently fang's earliest known
engagement was swallow occurred
through that chinese student association
and she developed close ties to
swahwell's office
at that time and for her targeting
suaville made sense
because his 2012 campaign relied heavily
on asian american support
which made his ties to the chinese
community particularly important
now again we know of the ties with
suawell we also know of a couple of ties
to an older midwestern mayor from an
obscure city who referred to fang as his
girlfriend
in 2014. fang also had a sexual
encounter with an ohio mayor and a car
that was under electronic fbi
surveillance so the bottom line is that
the chinese believe that they have a way
into american politics
and they're not wrong it also happens to
be the case
that the intelligence community
announced halfway through this year that
they were targeting the biden
campaign for victory they wanted the
biden campaign to win they were very
adverse and and angry at the trump
administration for its anti-china
position
and they were hopeful that joe biden
would be a solid replacement so look for
this sort of activity to pick up
also look for the media to completely
downplay the swalwall allegations
for his part kevin mccarthy who is the
house minority leader and and by the way
as we'll see in just a second the house
majority for the democrats is now down
to two seats
two okay which is pretty amazing
considering
that again they were expected to pick up
seats because
biden has picked martial fudge now to
run housing and urban development
which means they only have 220
democratic seats in the house okay
that that democratic delegation
is um yeah is is rife for
for problems okay so the so the
democratic party is in trouble and don't
worry the media are going to do not make
a big issue out of representative
eric swalwell but here is kevin mccarthy
by the way who is saying that swallow
should definitely not be on the
intelligence
committee he says representative swallow
has long been disqualified from serving
on the intel committee for years he
peddled russian disinformation for
political gain
now we find out he was involved in an
effort by a reported spy to gather
information for china
swallow is a national security liability
okay in just one second we are going to
get to
joe biden and the people he is picking
because again the democratic
delegation that democratic coalition it
looks like it's on the rocks already
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about a great holiday
gift you know something that the person
that you are giving to can use every
single day i'm talking of course
about the magic of earbuds earbuds are
just fantastic they're great you're
listening to media all the time
including shows like this one
but you don't want to spend a fortune on
your earbuds and you want them to fit
your ear perfectly well this is why
you need raycons okay go get some raycon
wireless earbuds today with seamless
bluetooth pairing a comfortable noise
isolating fit
you can start listening right out of the
box and keep listening for hours the
audio quality is amazing
comparable to what you get from other
premium brands except raycon
start at half the price best of all this
is something they can use for calls or
music for work or play at home or on the
go it's a gift
that keeps on giving in if they've
already got a pair of wireless earbuds
you always need a spare
raycon is being generous for the
holidays on top of their everyday great
prices they're offering my listeners
15 off right now go to byracon.com today
get that 15
off your recon order that is b u y r a y
c o n dot com
slash ben by raycon dot com slash band b
u y r a y c o n dot com
get 15 off i love my raycons they fit my
ear perfectly because you can actually
customize them you can do that for fit
you do that for color
check them out right now buy raycon dot
com slash man again that is by raycon
dot com slash ben okay meanwhile joe
biden is
picking people for his supposed team
and he doesn't know who they are he's
just being fed a certain number of
people
by various interest groups and this is
seriously how he's picking cabinet
members
he's not really picking them for
qualifications he's picking them solely
based on intersectional criteria
this is how he's ending up with xavier
becerra who's a wildly
partisan hack from california attorney
general the state of california who's
gone after pro-lifers has gone after
churches
for health and human services which is
just a disaster because one of the great
moves by the trump administration was to
de-politicize health care
by allowing religious institutions not
to cover
care that violated their religious
prescriptions remember the obama
administration wanted to force
nuns to at least sign off on
contraceptive coverage for people
right the obama administration would
love for religious business owners to
have to pay for abortions essentially
well presumably xavier bacero would want
exactly the same thing so
joe biden named him to the cabinet
mainly because he is latino
the funny thing here is that biden
clearly has no idea who he is he
completely blows his name
i mean in magical fashion if a
republican blew becerra's name this way
there would immediately
be cries of racism because how dare you
mispronounce it xavier becerra's name
here is joe biden absolutely mangling
this thing
for secretary of health and education
server i nominated
javier baqueria you know javier
bashir excuse me whoa bacharia
well and you don't want to come down
with it with a bad case of bacharia
sounds like that would hurt sounds like
that could be unpleasant
so there's joe biden who is not with it
again the man is just a facade for
whatever
the rest of the democratic party wants
him to be he is not some sort of
stalwart standing
in the gap in favor of moderation and
unity as the media would like to portray
him
some of the other people he is picking
he has selected representative marcia
fudge of ohio to serve as secretary for
housing and urban development in his
administration
it's a weird pick because the democrats
honestly need the votes in the house
taking a vote out of the democratic
house now there will have to be a
special election
to fill that particular seat it's a very
very weird move except for the fact that
he wants more black faces inside his
administration he has said this right
it's not me saying this
this is him saying this which is racist
okay if you suggested that you were
simply staffing your administration on
the basis of race sex and sexual
orientation
that basically you were casting some
sort of diverse street gang for netflix
then everybody would rightly point out
how racially insensitive that was but
that's exactly
what biden is doing so he's picked
marsha fudge of ohio
to serve as secretary of housing and
urban development tom vilsack has been
suggest has been picked before ag
secretary of course vilsack was already
in that position
right he'd return to that post held
during the obama administration so
basically the entire
biden team is retreads people he was
friends with when he was in the obama
administration and
a bunch of racially diverse faces he
knows nothing about that is the entire
administration
fudge was basically picked because her
allies had urged him to nominate her to
run the agriculture department
and and instead he was like you know
what i'm gonna pick vilsack for
agriculture you get to do housing and
urban development
representative james clyburn who is of
course a big ally of biden during the
campaign
he was the one who had suggested that
fudge be picked for the cabinet
but as even the new york times notes
picking fudge adds strain on speaker
nancy pelosi whose majority in the house
had shrunk to a handful of seats after
the elections
in november biden's decision to select
fudge for his cabinet means democrats
must win another special election to
fill her seat or risk the party's margin
shrinking
even further okay meanwhile speaking of
that
biden intersectional cabinet so you
recall there was a bit of an
intersectional battle going on over the
defense
secretary position michelle floor and i
was widely perceived to be the front
runner for secretary of defense
and many members of the democratic
coalition were super excited because we
need a woman
to be the head of the defense department
it would have been a groundbreaking move
to have a woman
be the head of the defense department
sure the term woman doesn't actually
mean anything
but still super duper important because
the category woman is both completely
malleable and meaningless and also
incredibly incredibly important to break
glass ceilings or or some such
in any case he didn't pick michelle
flournoy apparently biden didn't pick
her because number one he wasn't
particularly close to her there were
also some questions about
her lobbying for outside of government
organizations on k street
instead he chose lloyd austin so lloyd
austin
is a four-star general who retired about
four years ago this means that
the congress needs to pass a waiver in
order to make him a secretary of defense
lloyd austin also happens to be black so
this is going to be joe biden's cover
i mean literally to get away with it
with his own coalition
he over and over in this piece in the
atlantic he just keeps mentioning the
guys the guy's race like
it's super important that this guy is
black now we have had
high ranking black officials and we
we've had colin powell as secretary of
state
we had conolisa rice as secretary of
state under the obama administration
we had an attorney general who was black
the notion that it is like a
groundbreaking thing to have black
people in position we had a president of
the united states where two terms was
black
this idea that we needed the secretary
of defense to be black because otherwise
the intersexual
intersectional coalition is displeased
just demonstrates how fragile that
coalition is if all you can do
is hold that thing together with spit
and tape
because really it's just a bunch of
various interests and you just do a bit
of pork barrel rolling
selecting cabinet members by race and
sex that is not a solid coalition
joe biden's excuse for why he picked
lloyd austin is pretty astonishing he
says in late august of 2010
i traveled to iraq for the fifth time as
vice president while there i
participated in the change of command
ceremony for u.s
forces iraq president obama had charged
me with overseeing the end of operation
iraqi freedom
we are committed to ensuring the orderly
withdrawal of our forces and equipment
from iraq standing in the garish all
fall palace once home to saddam hussein
but by then part of camp victory i
watched as general lloyd austin assumed
leadership of a national security
priority on behalf of the president of
the united states
just over a year later in december 2011
i returned to alpha palace joining
austin
in a ceremony honoring american and
iraqi service members as our forces
left the country general austin got the
job done he played a crucial role in
bringing 150 000 american troops home
from that theater
of war now um i do recall that
immediately upon withdrawing from iraq
isis proceeded to establish a caliphate
directly in that region and iran rushed
to fill the vacuum
right and you would think that joe biden
forgot that but apparently trobiden did
not forget that because then he praises
lloyd austin for having to put together
the operation that went and fought isis
afterward
in the same piece so really well done
there vice president
biden so the you know his uh again he
just keeps
pushing on his race in this piece he
says he was the 200th person ever to
attain the rank of an army four-star
general only the sixth african-american
he was the first african-american
general officer to lead an army corps in
combat
the first african-american to command an
entire theater of war if confirmed
you'll be the first african american to
help the defense department
another milestone in a barrier-breaking
career
and so it's pretty obvious why he is
picking lloyd austin i mean lloyd austin
may in fact be a very good general i
don't know that much about the guy
i do know that he was delegated hundreds
of millions of dollars in order to build
up some sort of ground force to oppose
the assad regime in syria and came up
with something like 60 fighters with
something like
500 million or something but with that
said
maybe he's great at his job that ain't
why biden picked him
okay speaking of which you can see this
coalition already starting to fracture
bernie sanders
he says i'm not seeing enough
progressives in this administration
i want more of my people in this
administration if you think that the
bernie sanders wing of the party is
simply going to sit down and shut up you
have another thing coming which means
that biden is going to have to do one of
two things either he's going to have to
continue brushing off bernie
and his friends or with a very very slim
house majority
he is going to have to start catering to
aoc and bernie
and this administration will just become
a potemkin village
in favor of the radical left here's
bernie sanders expressing his
displeasure
my point has been from day one
that those voices that movement
deserves representation uh in the
cabinet
uh and if your question is have i seen
that yet uh
no i have not i've seen some good
appointments uh people that i like i
think people who are
really really smart experienced
uh but i have not seen uh people from
the
progressive movement per se uh
in that cabinet okay so what exactly is
joe biden gonna do about that continue
to brush off bernie or
as that house majority shrinks and
shrinks and shrinks is he gonna have to
start catering
more and more to his radical left flank
in just one second
we're gonna get to joe biden's supposed
outreach effort to conservatives
which um even members of the media
they're immediately like why is even
bothering
stop doing outreach to conservatives so
first of all i think it's a sham but
second of all
i also think that the media will not
allow him to do this even if it were
genuine we'll get to that in just one
second first
let me tell you about one of my favorite
foods so i'm a waffle guy people ask
pancakes or waffles i'm a waffle person
my kids
every morning they've got the waffles
well i just got
the coolest device ever i'm talking
about the presto stuffler stuffed waffle
maker so you thought
that stuffed waffles this was just like
putting you know chocolate chips inner
waffle or something okay the
presto stuffler stuffed waffle maker
this can make a meal out of pretty much
anything it's fantastic the folks at
presto have taken the waffle to new
heights with their stuffler stuffed
waffle maker it cooks belgian style
waffles with your families families
favorite foods inside whether you're
talking about sweet or savory whether
you're talking about fruits chocolate
cheesecake pie fillings nuts candy or
savory like chicken or meat or eggs or
cheese or veggies
it is unbelievably good and if you
haven't thought by the way about doing
something like chicken inside your
waffles you're completely missing out
it's amazing amazing
stuff the stuffler is easy to use it
works with any batter not just waffle
mixes but also cake muffin and brownie
both boxed and
from scratch you just pour in the batter
add stuffing fill with more batter close
that cover flip 180 degrees
and cook and when you're done you take
out the waffle with these built-in
waffle tongs and then
you'll have the best waffle you have
ever tasted it is absolutely fantastic
also you can check out the fact that
there are batters out there that are
keto friendly and gluten free friendly
as well make sure that you check this
thing out presto will provide you dozens
of recipes and ideas for intriguing
batters and delicious stuffings it's a
fantastic hanukkah or christmas gift
i've been using it with my family
already and my kids are just in love
with this thing go to www.stuffler.com
click the buy now and then the add to
cart button enter promo code ben you get
off today again that's stufflord.com
s-t-u-f-f-l-e-r.com promo code ben after
you add to the cart i'm the biggest
waffle fan on the planet my kids are too
they love this thing your family's gonna
love it just as much go to stuffler.com
use a promo code ben after you add the
device to the cart and get 10
off already in just one second we're
going to get to joe biden's supposed
outreach effort
to conservatives and then we'll get to
his attempt to hijack
all of the progress made under president
trump against covet and pretend that he
is responsible
for it but first you may have noticed
something on this desk you may have
noticed something magical and new
oh yeah check this baby out this is the
new
improved leftist years tumbler you can
keep those leftist tiers hot or cold
in a new stainless steel design with
that custom daily wire lid
check that baby out very very snazzy
stuff also
if you are not already a daily wire
member now is the time to join we have
some amazing stuff coming up right
around the corner the michael knowles
show is now five days a week adding more
content for our members to enjoy we are
also adding
the entire prageru catalog to
dailywire.com by the end of the year
we've already uploaded all of prageru's
five minute videos the candice owens
show from prageru michael knowles book
club the rest of the library is being
added as we speak also early next year
kenneth owens
joins the daily wear in nashville she'll
be launching a show unlike anything else
in conservative media
in front of a live studio audience we
are also going to be getting into the
feature film business so you may have
noticed
that hollywood continues to churn out
content that is directly related to
insulting you and your values well not
so over here at daily wear we're going
to be competing directly
with hollywood we're doing mainstream
films and we're talking about our rated
films edgy stuff too
because we know that at night when you
turn on the tv sometimes you want to
watch something
that is not just going to be sesame
street we are building a new
investigative journalism team to replace
the legacy media cartel so
go outside the narrative come over to
dailywire.com subscribe
it's really important honestly like if
you want an alternative to the
establishment media you need to give us
your support and companies like ours
also if you have not yet ordered our
daily wear christmas tree ornaments
you have until today today is the last
day december 9th to get them in time to
decorate that tree
that would be all of the daily wire
house plus god king jeremy boring and
santa's
adorable elves made out of painted metal
ah yes
you can see the likeness of andrew
clavin space alien
jeremy boring bizarrely bearded human
dower matt walsh michael knowles an
actual
santa's elf and an orthodox john a
christmas ornament i know why
text christmas to 83 400 to get your
tree decorated today they are going fast
get yours right now you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so joe biden is playing a game
with the media where he pursues
hard left policy and heartless left
cabinet picks by the way while
simultaneously claiming that he's
captain unity this is his favorite thing
to do he's been doing it throughout the
campaign he's here to unify americans to
bring them back together and
listen if you were going to treat
conservatives with any level of
consideration and class
that would amount to something better
than what we've had from the left for
several years and many years at this
point but i don't think that's likely to
happen i think what is likely to happen
is he's going to say i reached out and
they slapped my hand you can see the
predicate being set
right now according to bloomberg the
biden administration plans to create a
position to find common ground with
conservatives according to louisiana
congressman cedric richmond
a senior advisor and director of the
office of public engagement for
joe biden he said during a wall street
journal ceo council monday night right
now i'm trying to set up the office
i'm actually looking at establishing a
position that reaches out to
conservatives because it's about moving
forward we cannot stay
where we are yes i cannot wait to see
them recruit jeff flake
or john kasich in order to reach out to
conservatives good luck
with that now i'm skeptical because i
just don't think that it's going to be a
genuine attempt to reach out to
conservatives i think that there is too
much
in the democratic platform that is
directly related to culture war
anti-conservatism
for the democrats to credibly do this
but members of the media
are even more upset about the
possibility that joe biden might reach
across the aisle in terms of actual
policy
so paul waldman has a piece of the
washington post saying you should never
reach out to conservatives
this is my favorite part of the
revisionist history of the last 15 years
is where democrats suggest that barack
obama tried to reach out across the
aisle
at no point did barack obama ever care
about reaching out across the aisle
that was not a thing he cared about he
saw the other side of the aisle as
vicious and racist
he basically says so directly in his
memoir and yet there's this myth-making
that every democrat is bipartisan and
every republican is a partisan hack even
though george w bush was the most
bipartisan president
of my lifetime uh it doesn't matter the
the idea is that
republicans are direly partisan and
political while democrats are
wonderfully unifying
and paul waldman has a piece today he's
saying president-elect joe biden is not
giving up
on reaching out to people who didn't
vote for him even as most of them seem
to believe he's at the plot
the head of a plot to steal the election
and a significant portion believe he's a
global
conspiracist of satanic pedophile
cannibals sex traffickers
oh god these people how many how many
people think that like seriously
inside the republican coalition how many
people think that joe biden is the head
of a global conspiracy
of satanic pedophile cannibal sex
traffickers like how many
three okay but but apparently according
to paul waldman it's like running
it's running rife through the republican
halls of power
biden is determined though just as so
many democrats were before him says paul
it's democrats famous for reaching
across the aisle and like them
he'll probably fail it's the right thing
to reach across the other side of the
aisle says paul waldman he'll be
supporting policies he believes are good
for the whole country
not just places in the country that
supported him but it won't help this is
a never-ending obsession with democrats
how can we get conservatives to like us
more is there some special strategy we
can deploy
or argument we can make that will open
up their hearts and minds what we have
to say
you may have noticed republicans never
bother to ask themselves how they might
reach out to liberals they appoint no
people to carry out this task they
publish no essays in their journals
about how to go about it they hold the
think-tank forums to explore the problem
and consider solutions
they'd much rather dream up new voter
suppression schemes to make it more
difficult for liberals to cast their
bouts this is my favorite brand
of leftist thought is how dare anybody
on our side reach out to the other side
the other side is evil we shouldn't
reach out to them and
sure we're bipartisan sure we think it's
a great idea but the other side is just
so
evil the castigation of the other side
is completely evil you know people who
believe in demonic possession
of joe biden or people who believe in
voter suppression
so you can't reach out to them the goal
here is not of course bipartisanship the
goal is not to come together around any
sort of common theme
the goal here is to make sure that that
never happens
so according to paul waldman the truth
is that democrats reach out constantly
constantly
i have a question when is the last time
a democrat reached out to you to try and
understand your position
okay when hollywood makes a movie called
hillbilly elegy that is designed
to try and understand people who might
have voted for trump the critics
immediately savage it by saying that
there should be no movies
that attempt to understand those voters
instead democrats keep banking
on this coalition of the ascendant
nonsense that they
coined in 2012. so no joe biden's not
going to be bringing anybody together
because his own party will not let him
and because joe biden is wedded to
certain principles that undercut the
possibility of coming together if you
want the country to come together there
have to be shared principles democrats
reject
many of those shared principles they
don't have to they don't have to
right some of those shared principles
would include the idea that america is
fundamentally a good country i think joe
biden deep down
actually kind of believes that but he
has been roped into the 16-19 project
mentality by his own intersectional
coalition
i think the deep down joe biden is not
averse
to the to the basic idea that individual
rights matter
but i think that he has been roped into
the idea that individual rights ought to
be put aside
in favor of specific benefits for
particular members of the coalitional
group
there are ways americans can come
together but not if you have the kind of
divides the democrats have been
embracing for years on end and the
culture war castigation of anyone who
disagrees
as an element of evil okay meanwhile
oncovit
uh president trump announced yesterday
the fda is about to authorize the
distribution
of the vaccine that is already being
distributed in the uk here is president
trump announcing this yesterday
we're very hopeful that the fda will
authorize
the fisa vaccine within days we've got
to
get it moving and modern vaccine
almost immediately thereafter large
numbers of tests and samples have been
done
so hopefully that'll go very quickly if
authorized tens of millions of vaccine
doses will be available this month
and we'll get it distributed very
quickly we have that all said
okay so because trump is actually
succeeding in helping to develop the
vaccine with operation warp speed and
because there is in fact a distribution
plan
in place the media immediately suggests
the reason that trump came out and and
talked about it yesterday is because
he's afraid biden is going to get credit
well first of all biden shouldn't get
credit he has no power how the hell
would biden get credit for this you know
that's what's going to happen by the way
we'll hit january february and it'll be
look at how joe biden solved the
pandemic isn't that incredible he'll
have done
absolutely zero things that solve the
pandemic and the media will be
slobbering all over him
it'll be just like after barack obama
was given the nobel prize for being a
breathing human
who is black right i mean that who
became president that's the only reason
that barack obama
was given the nobel i mean to his own
credit he himself was like i don't even
know why i'm being given this award but
watch as joe biden is giving that sort
of credit here's nbc getting very angry
that trump would want credit for some of
his achievements in fighting covet
this is really an opportunity for the
president who is afraid that his
successor joe biden
is going to get a bulk of the kudos
since he's going to have to oversee the
distribution process when he takes
office next month
he is very concerned about that and we
know that because he has said
it wasn't joe biden who did anything on
the vaccines it was all
me me me that seems to be his focus
today here at the white house crosstalk
me me me as opposed to joe biden who
keeps saying over and over that you have
to listen to me
and wear masks joe biden has done zero
things
zero things and by the way all he'll be
doing is implementing plans that were
already in place
uh if and when he takes office meanwhile
over in britain
there are some fears over the coveted
vaccine and i
assume these will be short-lived after a
couple of healthcare workers had
anaphylactic reactions
hours after the taking of the vaccine
british authorities then told anyone
with a severe allergy or to food or
medicine
not to take the vaccine right away the
fda is according to the daily mail is
due to meat tomorrow to discuss green
lighting the vaccine in america
after being lambasted for taking a week
longer than the breads to get it off the
ground
in a preliminary analysis posted online
on tuesday one group of fda scientists
said it was safe it is always hard to
tell when you have like two
bad reactions out of tens of thousands
of reactions whether
that is because of the vaccine or
whether it was because of something else
among the 20 000 people who were given
the vaccine in pfizer's global trial
137 had allergic reactions so did 111
people who are given the placebo
so scientists basically said okay well
obviously the vaccine is not the
deciding factor
right here there were four people among
the 20 000 who did get bell's palsy
after receiving it which is a type of
facial paralysis
trial scientists said it was not
necessarily the jab that caused it that
was on par with the general rate of
bell's palsy in the wider
population but the british health and
medicare
products regulatory agency is now
warning people with a severe food
food allergy or medical allergy not to
get that drug
in america that applies to at least 200
000 people who have food allergies and
many more who have
drug allergies apparently the two
healthcare workers were both carry
epipens no other information
has been given it's also unclear if
they're the only ones who had adverse
reactions
at this point the pfizer vaccine
according to the daily mail comes in two
injections whether or not they can now
take the second or whether it's safe
to for them to do so is under scrutiny
it's also unclear if they'll be able to
take any other type of future vaccine
by moderna okay this there's a large
swath of skepticism regarding the
benefits of taking the vaccine there was
a tweet that sort of went viral
yesterday uh in which somebody suggested
that you are 99
likely to live if you get coveted and
you're only 95
likely to live if you get the vaccine
that's not exactly correct basically the
vaccine
is 95 effective in preventing you from
obtaining kobit in the first place
and then after that the remaining five
percent of people then they have
basically a 99 shot at living this is
particularly this particularly means
that when we trash this thing out
we should be tranching it out in terms
of people who are most at risk in other
words
if you have a five-year-old kid i'm not
sure that a five-year-old kid needs to
get the vaccine
i mean the five-year-old kids are not at
risk from this thing now
my kids do get the flu vaccine i get the
flu vaccine i'm a big believer in
vaccines and
if a vaccine can lessen the severity
which is what the early data preliminary
data suggests
from these coveted trials they suggest
that people who got severe covet
the vast majority of them were in the
placebo group they were not in the
actual vaccination group
and according to the cdc the vaccine may
help you from getting seriously ill even
if you do get
covid 19. okay we should be tranching
this out to the populations who are most
at risk
obviously and by the way if you do get
the vaccine you should expect there are
going to be
some mild side effects that is not rare
there are some mild side effects
like your arm is going to hurt um there
were severe side effects
in a certain percentage of patients in
the moderna trial according to
science.com
most people would escape severe side
effects there were transient reactions
again like your arm is sore
but there are some more severe side
effects defined as those that prevent
daily activity they usually last around
a day according to
the according to the studies that have
already been done the independent board
that conducted the interim analysis of
modernist trial found that severe side
effects included fatigue in about 10
muscle pain at about nine percent joint
pain and five percent headache and 4.5
percent severe side effects also
included fatigue and headache and the
pfizer vaccine trial is about 3.8
percent
and 2 that's a higher rate of severe
reactions than people may be accustomed
to
but people are getting over this fairly
quickly and these are not generally long
lasting so far
as the data present right now now what
is joe biden doing about all of this i
mean this is all
incredible right i mean we've developed
an mrna vaccine in record time it has
never been done before
anything remotely like this so joe biden
naturally is suggesting that he has the
solution the solution is he's going to
tell people to wear masks on the first
day
and now the rate of mask adherence in
the united states is very high
by pulling data people are wearing masks
even out here in florida where we are
much looser with the guidelines than
they were in california
nearly everybody is wearing a mask at
nearly all times in the area where i'm
living
so i can tell you people are wearing the
masks but joe biden somehow thinks that
if he says mass mass mass mask over and
over again that this is going to cure
the pandemic or alternatively
he knows that it won't it's just that
the media will give him credit because
this is one area where trump chose to
draw a contrast
for no rational reason i can think of
here was joe biden
i'm going to ask for a masking plan
everyone for the first hundred days of
my administration to wear a mask
it will start with my sign in order on
day one to require
masks where i can under the law like
federal buildings
interstate travel on planes trains and
buses
i'll also be working with the governors
and mayors to do the same
in their states and their cities we're
going to require mask wherever possible
okay just a quick note here if you fly
commercially in the united states you're
wearing a mask on the plane
yeah that's already existing as far as
interstate travel on trains i assume
that the same case is true in other
words he's already doing stuff that
everybody knows
they're doing i mean he's not he's not
actually changing anything this is all
posturing for the cameras
and the media just eat it up the media
love it they also love the fact that
anthony fauci spoke from abide in
presser yesterday he made his debut as a
member of the biden team yesterday here
was anthony fauci yesterday speaking
from from biden's podium i believe
as you do that in the fight against this
pandemic
we must lead with science and that a key
piece
of our ongoing work is communicating
consistently
with the american people whether it's
maintaining
social distancing and not congregating
indoors
or the 100-day challenge you described
on masking
or to get as many people vaccinated as
possible
these actions are bold they're bold
action
my god it's amazing remember we kept
hearing about the suck opery of the
various public health officials to trump
i mean that's that's some serious
sycophantic crap right there okay
everybody already knows this stuff we've
been talking about it for months but
apparently it's bold action bold action
now from anthony fouche
okay in one second we're gonna get to
joe biden and and the the coverage of
the media about all this because here's
the thing
it turns out that he's not actually
following the science in certain
particular areas okay so
all of this biden policy right these
magical policies the media are just in
love
with them right he's got anthony fauci
out there saying that he's taking bold
action
he's not taking bold action he's not
changing anything all this stuff is
already in place okay but here's how the
new york times is covering joe biden's
plan to fight covet remember
joe biden would not be inaugurated until
the end of january
according to the new york times joe
biden setting ambitious goals ambitious
goals
to change the course of the coronavirus
pandemic vowed on tuesday to get at
least 100 million cobra vaccine shots
into the arms of the american people
during his first 100 days in office you
might at this point stop and ask
yourself
what was the plan if uh trump were to be
re-elected and stay in office the plan
is 100 million shots so literally
nothing changed
his entire plan is the trump plan and
this was the entire campaign it was so
annoying joe biden would just say the
same crap that trump was saying and then
he'd be like i have a new i have a new
plan and
my plan is and
they turned into meg ryan and when harry
met sally
every time joe biden would say exactly
like he would take out trump's plan read
it verbatim
they'd be like that's an amazing plan
joe biden it turns out that joe biden's
been able to get away with plagiarism
literally his entire
career including of trump's vaccine plan
he said he would make it a national
priority to get children back to school
during that time
oh well would you joe biden hmm some
people were saying for months the kids
should be back in school
including president trump and guess who
was saying you know we're not sure about
that would be members of your own
campaign appearing in wilmington
delaware to introduce members of his
health team
biden pledged to run quote the most
efficient mass vaccination plan in us
history but did not say helen through
what
companies his administration would
purchase vaccine shots mr biden also
implored americans to wear masks during
his first 100 days in office
and said he would make doing so a
requirement biden said my first 100 days
won't and then covet 19 virus i can't
promise that
well you literally promised that in your
campaign you said that you weren't going
to end the economy you were going to end
the virus
so what happened i mean all of a sudden
your captain
accuracy hmm he says i'm absolutely
convinced in 100 days we can change the
course of the
disease and change life in america for
the better well well that's a that's
that's a non-big standard there by the
way i can also predict that in the first
hundred days
of the next administration that the
pandemic will wane you know how i can
predict this
because of course it's going to wane
every single public health official says
it's going to wayne we're going to hit
the worst of this
in december and in january and the
vaccines are going to be rolled out by
the tens of millions by january february
and march
so wow okay nostradamus over there
biden's announcement offered a telling
split-screen counterpart to an event
being held at the same time as the white
house
a vaccine summit where trump boasted
about what he called a monumental
national development by drug companies
to develop a vaccine for the virus in
about nine months
okay that's not just what trump
characterized that as that is a
monumental national achievement we have
never had a vaccine developed this way
not nearly that fast it on average takes
vaccines you know five ten years to be
developed
he did not address the growing death
toll or devastation across the country
but he used the occasion to suggest yet
again and without evidence people have
tried to steal the election
meanwhile the next administration was
clearly taking shape according to the
new york times
the senior officials will face the
immediate challenge of slowing the
spread of the coronavirus
amazing it's just wow so impressive so
wonderful
so bold so unbelievable okay and they're
gonna follow the science i mean this is
what we've been told
they're going to follow the science
except that they're not
okay so joe biden turned this into a
racial issue this has been one of my
bugaboos since the beginning
of the pandemic is the desire by the
media to turn this into a racial issue
a disproportionate number of black and
latino people are dying of the virus
now the suggestion is this is because of
systemic american racism there is no
evidence whatsoever this is the effect
of systemic american racism
okay poverty leads people
to be in close quarters with other
people where they live
it leads them to have to work at jobs in
which they're in close quarters with
other people
and that means that covet transmits more
easily it is also quite possible that
certain segments of the population
and i include among these segments of
the population orthodox jews by the way
have a tendency to get together in large
groups when they often should not and
this transmit the virus at higher rates
than other people
but the media have been pushing this
idea since the very beginning that if a
disproportionate number of
black americans die of covet 19 that
can't have anything to do with the
disproportionate
pre-existing conditions in the black
community like heart disease and obesity
which in fact are disproportionate in
the black community
instead it has to do with the fact that
america is racist
so here is joe biden making that case
this is not science this is this is just
racial pandering more than 285
000 dead americans because of cove 19
and counting last week
cover 19 was the number one cause of
death in america
for black latino and native americans
who are nearly three
times as likely to die from it cova 19
is a
mass casualty okay so it's a mass
casualty actually for people with
pre-existing conditions who happen to be
elderly
okay this is this is why i say this is
unscientific
if you have two categories that could
apply to a particular descriptor
one is more scientifically exact than
the other so this is a perfect example
a a disproportionate number of black
americans are dying of covenant 19.
that would suggest that the virus is
targeting black people but
a better descriptor would be cova-19 it
disproportionately affects those with
pre-existing conditions
black americans tend to have those
pre-existing conditions in higher
numbers
that is why black people are dying at
higher rates than other people
and this happens to be true in europe as
well not just in the united states
okay so perhaps if you were going to
tailor a program
to vaccinate you would tailor it toward
health condition right you wouldn't
tailor it toward race
you would tailor it toward health
condition because otherwise you are
committing what is called
in statistics a category error right you
are using a category that is not the
most descriptive category
in order to take a measure that is not
going to be the most
the most closely tailored to solve the
problem
this is why i say that the biden and
company members the media they're
playing politics with this sort of stuff
if you actually want to target the
people who are most vulnerable you
wouldn't do it by race
that is a category error you would do it
instead by pre-existing condition
you wouldn't even do it by age by the
way you would do it by pre-existing
condition dr martin makari is a regular
guest on this program from johns hopkins
university
he did a study where he and his fellows
over at johns hopkins
they analyzed 250 000 american deaths
this is about a month ago
and what they found is that for people
who are enrolled in medicare basically
everybody in the united states above the
age of 65
the grand total number of people
enrolled in medicare who died of covet
with no pre-existing conditions none
was 2500 out of 250 000 dead
what does that suggest that age isn't
even the deciding factor here
pre-existing condition is the deciding
factor here
so if you're going to roll out the
vaccine the way that you should tailor
the vaccine rollout
is not by race it is not even by age it
is by preexisting health condition
and here is where the rubber meets the
road because when it comes to vaccine
distribution that is not what is
actually
being done so for example there is a
doctor
named angie rasmussen and angie
rasmussen
tweeted out as we start to absorb the
data that fizer submitted to the fda and
get ready for vaccines to roll out we
need to start thinking about
distribution
i agree with scott gottlieb equity needs
to be front and center as we consider
how to do this equity
not health equity okay she's quoting an
op-ed
from scott gottlieb former fda
commissioner under trump he said the
best option may be to inoculate those
over 65 with a focus
on low-income communities well
no the focus should be on tranching this
out by pre-existing condition
that's the way that you actually handle
this thing now that will
disproportionately fall on people over
the age of 65 and in low-income
communities right
but the idea of treating this as an
equity issue as opposed to a health
issue
is designed explicitly to divide us
politically because the idea
is that all health issues are are in
fact equity issues
right any inequality of outcome is
inequality
in the system itself this is the this is
the
push that is being made by the biden
team okay this is why biden hosted a
professor
named nunes smith who suggested that
blacks and latinx americans
were suffering from a quote-unquote
grief gap thanks to kovid
turning this into a racial issue is not
that is not what the health
guidance suggests black people are not
dying because they are black
the virus isn't racist and neither is
the health system i'm sorry but if you
go to a hospital
doctors are not sitting there going okay
black guy push him over to the side let
him
go without the respirator we got a white
person here we got a fat old white guy
he's probably gonna die we've got a
healthy black person there
put that healthy black person inside
because he's black not because he's
healthy because he's black
that is not what is happening in
hospitals across the united states
nonetheless biden has to turn this into
a racial issue and this is gonna be
captain unity over here so here's
professor
nunez smith a member of the biden health
team
it is not a coincidence and it is not a
matter of genetics
that more than 70 percent of african
americans
and more than 60 of latinx americans
personally know someone who has been
hospitalized
or died from coven 19.
the same disparities ingrained in our
economy
our housing system our food system our
justice system
and so many other areas of our society
have conspired
in this moment to create a grief gap
that we cannot ignore okay this is such
gross politics it is
this person her name is marcella nunez
smith she's a racism
scholar and she's going to head up joe
biden's covenant 19 equity
task force she's a top yale university
academic
and she was signed up to serve in the
biden administration her work on health
inequalities and particularly those
entwined
racial and economic lines make her a
clear choice to lead an effort to
address one of the pandemic's most
shocking
and unavoidable effects the deadly
exacerbation of existing disparities in
health income and well-being across the
us population as a whole is according to
the uk
independent dr nunez smith told the ap
recently the scale of the disparity
means almost 50 percent of people in
this country
know someone who has died of covet at
19. but
this is going to be just another excuse
to engage
in radical leveling right this is the
same kind of person she describes how
she herself she's a graduate i believe
of yale school of medicine i believe uh
she herself has
often been subject of racial
microaggressions in her medical career
a lot of the time she told the site if
it was a patient not of color they'd
make assumptions about my role
to this day as an attending physician at
yale patients are constantly handing me
their trades and asking if i can call
their doctor and i'm their attending
physician of record and we have met
several times
okay um then your patients are idiots i
mean i i hate to break it to you that
might be because your patient's a
doctors and nurses wear different
uniforms at hospitals my wife works at
hospitals
they don't wear the same coats okay but
again the this this is the basic idea
that all disparities can be chalked up
to systemic american inequalities
this is how these things get political
it's when joe biden says he's guided by
the science no
he is absolutely not guided by the
science he is guided by politics always
and forever and so are the democrats
more broadly to pretend otherwise is to
ignore what exactly
a biden team is going to be doing on
kovit claiming all the credit for all
the achievements of the trump
administration while simultaneously
suggesting that the american system is
racist sexist bigoted and homophobic
and that all it's amazing every problem
has the same solution if you're a
democrat
every problem has the same solution and
that is to blame the american system for
any inequality of
outcome in any arena of american life
from maternal mortality
which has confounds what we call
statistical confounds there are reasons
for differentials in maternal mortality
across races
very often it has to do with maternal
weight for example
in maternal health but what what the
left keeps doing is then they just
remove one step they say oh well yeah
but the reason that those health
circumstances exist is because america
is racist in the first place
it's the god of the gabs it's the racism
of the gaps for democrats
and so if there is a disparity they
can't actually see the racism in the
healthcare system so instead what they
do is they say well you know
it's probably not the racism in the
healthcare system it's it's racism in
the system
that created the healthcare system and
if you say well yeah but that's the
student's not racist either they say
yeah but it was the preconditions of
that system that created the healthcare
it's always
one step removed right you always just
zoom up
one one step in order to finally find
the racism that you have been seeking
and that is the
the politics that joe biden is bringing
to the table does that sound
science-based to you
now speaking of a non-science-based
policy democrats continue to hold up
covet relief mitch mcconnell has made at
this point several proposals the trump
administration made
more than a trillion dollars of
proposals for covered relief before the
election
and you'll recall that nancy pelosi just
a couple of days ago announced that she
had held up coveted relief
for political reasons right she
literally came out and she said
yeah sure now i like to negotiate you
know what changed well now there's a new
president then a vaccine so she's
overtly admitting that she held up
relief to americans
who were being forced into poverty by
the federal and state governments
and she held that up because there was
an election coming that is a total
game changer a new president
and a vaccine so there's nothing to co
these are different what what was then
before was not more
of this this is has simplicity
it's what we've had in our bills it's
for a shorter period of time
but that's okay now because we have a
new president
okay that's amazing i mean there she was
just admitting straight out the reason
she didn't pass
covert relief that tens and tens of
hundreds of millions of americans
require at this point
is because she was playing politics
before the election by the way it
backfired on her since she lost a bevy
of house seats okay dick durbin has
admitted the same senator dick durbin
from illinois he admitted the democrats
held up the relief for the election as
well
there was some exuberance involved
because an election was coming
and they were both out bidding one
another and trying to find some common
ground they didn't reach that point
but to return to those pre-election days
and sentiments political sentiments
is very difficult we are looking at the
reality now of a new president coming on
board in just a few weeks
with president trump leaving we are
trying to find something that we can
agree to on a bipartisan basis on an
emergency
basis oh well so you know we were all
enthusiastic and people were outbidding
each other and we just decided not to do
any of those deals
because the election was coming so
democrats are pretty open about all of
this
well now they have flipped on a dime and
now they're saying we need the relief
right now we need the relief
the the pure political brinksmanship the
democrats were engaged in is so ugly and
so gross at this point
and so joe manchin from west virginia
has been fairly consistent in wanting a
covered relief bill
he's now saying nobody should go home
until it's done weird because you could
have done this two months ago guys
there's not one senator or one congress
person that should go home for christmas
if it's not done
i don't know how you face the people
that lost rent
food assistance shelter the basic
necessities of life and we're gonna say
well we're gonna go home and have a nice
christmas
yeah good luck okay and he happens to be
correct
about this now yesterday the media
started pushing the idea that
republicans were holding up the coveted
relief bill it doesn't matter they've
they've pushed a bunch of code relief
bills mcconnell has pushed a bunch of
them
so mcconnell yesterday was attempting to
put in the covered relief bill
liability protections for employers who
didn't want to close down
right so democrats want you to be able
to sue your employer if they want you to
be at work in the middle of the coven
pandemic and then you get covered
republicans say no we have a free
society and if you don't want to show up
for work because you're afraid of covid
well then you don't show up to work and
then your employer can do what your
employer wants to do
democrats object to this basic thing and
so mcconnell knew this was a sticking
point for democrats he said why don't we
throw that in a future bill
we'll throw a couple of things in a
future bill in fact we'll throw that in
a future bill
and we'll also throw more state relief
into a future bill and democrats like
nope
not going to do it and then they claim
that mitch mcconnell is the person
refusing to compromise
here's mcconnell yesterday proposing a
non-controversial relief bill
it remains my view that we ought to
pass what we can agree on and i think
that's a pretty broad area that includes
ppp vaccine delivery
additional assistance to health care
providers
and a variety of other things that are
not controversial okay but democrats
want the controversial stuff in there
because
every crisis is an opportunity whether
it is joe biden's
medical team pushing racial equity
issues
on the basis of covet or whether it is a
coveted relief bill the democrats want
to stuff with a bunch of crap
and then they'll hold up for the
election just for political gain
everything is politics
all of the things are politics so here's
where things currently stand according
to the new york times
jumps starting negotiations with dave's
despair the white house on tuesday
offered democrats a 916
billion pandemic stimulus proposal that
would meet their demand to provide some
relief to state and local governments
and include liability protections for
businesses that have been a top priority
of republicans
the offer from steve mnuchin the
treasury secretary tim pelosi was the
first time the trump administration has
engaged directly
with the democrats the plan does not
include a proposed revisal
uh revival of 300 weekly enhanced
unemployment benefits that would extend
other federal unemployment programs set
to expire
in the coming weeks instead it would
include another smaller round of direct
payments to americans amounting to 600
per person well that is because as
people get back to work and as the
vaccines
roll out the idea of continuing to
extend weekly enhanced unemployment
benefits
of 1200 bucks a month that is a real
disincentive for a lot of people who
need to get back into the job market
right this has been a serious concern
ever since
congress started passing these covered
relief bills the original 2.2 trillion
stimulus law enacted in march
distributed a round of 1200 stimulus
checks and established
those enhanced unemployment benefits at
600 a week through july
later trump extended those at 300 a week
for most workers
the proposal put forward by mnuchin
would not address elapsed benefit would
have the one-time
payment pelosi of course said the
president's proposal must not be allowed
to obstruct the bipartisan congressional
talks that are already underway
calling the cuts to unemployment
insurance benefits unacceptable weird
because mnuchin offered way to hell more
before the election but pelosi didn't
want any bit of it because she was too
busy
trying to uh trying to pretend that
republicans were obstructing coveted
relief for
political gain it's so gross it's really
gross representative kevin mccarthy
says it's a very good offer his focus is
on things that need to be there
and earlier of course mcconnell signaled
openness to a deal he floated the
possibility of removing both that
liability provision and funding for
state and local governments first of all
the fact that democrats want the trial
lawyers to get rich off of covet is
pretty insane
mcconnell said dropping both parties top
priorities could smooth the way for a
narrower deal
funding vaccine distribution schools and
small businesses
as well so is something you're gonna get
passed i'm sure will
is this deeply political stuff you bet
your ass is deeply political because for
the democrats there is no other way
there is no other way but for it to be
deeply political
now and going forward and after all now
that they think they want an election
this means that magically it's time to
deal alrighty so while you wait for two
additional hours of the ben shapiro show
later today head on over right now to
the michael mostro where he will be
talking about a former israeli space
chief describing a galactic federation
of aliens
weird stuff sounds like the u.n this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2020. a former
israeli space chief describes a galactic
federation of aliens the supreme court
deals a tough blow for the trump legal
team
and evidence emerges that china has
bought off many democrat elites check it
out on the michael knoll show